it's surpassed all our expectations in
every sense whether it's from the
attendance of fans
um
whether it's the learnings that we've
had from the
fifa arab cup
whether it's in the stadiums public
transport we've stress test a lot of our
operations which have been very good i
mean i can give you a few examples
20 to 25 percent of all fans who
attended the games used the metro in
public transport which is something that
hasn't happened before even in our
previous events
the other thing is we've tested the fan
id we had two hundred thousand as our
target to test and we've reached the
target of two hundred thousand fan ids
obviously with the fan ids there's a lot
of key learnings there and we're moving
into the next phase of testing uh prior
to the world cup and i mean that had a
lot of benefits in terms of testing it
the physical fan id the digital fan id
and we're confident now that we're going
to get it right
so i mean even in terms of the broadcast
the viewership was were really good i
think everybody's surprised by the
success of the tournament and uh there's
big calls for the tournament to continue
uh in its current format nasa you must
agree with me on this that our main
concern now is the actual covet 19. now
it's hitting all the sports
what is the plan are we still going to
have a full capacity stadium
we're hoping and quite confident that
when the world cup is around we'll have
full capacity stadiums we've seen that
now we've seen that um the
the group stages were at 75 capacity
then when we moved into the later stages
they went to 100 capacity and this is
also part of the test all the data
that's coming out from the ministry of
public health are quite good i don't
want to say positive but they're quite
good
um so we're confident we have strong
protocols in place so now as you know
we're the first country to have hosted
games with fans
during the pandemic
our protocols have been refined and
improved we've shared our protocols with
other governing sports governing bodies
they've implemented them whether in
whole or in part and we have our
protocols and policies for the world cup
ready right now that have been shared
so
we are as ready as we can be now the
rest is for
making sure the world is able to keep
kovid in check
if things get worse do you think it will
be like the olympics in tokyo and the
beijing games like that we're not going
to accept any fans
look i mean
i'm not a scientist
but in the medical world they
hopefully say that the worst is behind i
mean
whether it's on the on the um mutations
and the vaccines and the effectiveness
of these vaccines i mean we're hoping
that it'll only get better from here
now so let's talk about the issue that's
been overshadowing this world cup since
day one the human rights and we can't
ignore
the protest of some players
what do you respond to those protests
i think the players who protest have a
right to protest everybody has their
right on social positions and political
positions whatever they may be but what
we ask of the players specifically
because you know
they're quite vocal they have huge
followers
we ask of them to really understand the
facts
and stay away from what they read in
headlines stay away from campaigners
that have certain agendas behind them
because if they were to look at the
facts and to speak to reputa reputable
organizations that have been following
qatar's development and progress over
the past 10 years they will see that
what qatar has done in terms of workers
welfare worker standards improving their
working conditions is quite enormous and
over the span of 10 years
nothing like any nothing like this has
happened in the world um the
introduction of minimum wage and the
improving of accommodation standards um
and the abolishing of kafala giving
people the the freedom to move from one
employer to the other and these are all
have these are all enshrined in
legislation right now and you know
countries take decades and decades to
pass legislation and through parliament
and through the judicial bodies
anywhere in the world so people really
need to see the amount of work that
qatar has put the progress it has made
they need to put it into context of the
region and where qatar stands in the
region i'm sure that if these players
actually went to dig into the facts
rather than just listen to campaigners
and follow a trend they would understand
that instead of campaigning
against qatar they would actually be
campaigning for qatar and this is
something i urge all players they have a
responsibility because they have a huge
following they have a responsibility
because they are the reason this world
cup is happening is for them to contest
against other teams and ultimately lift
the trophy so i can't imagine being a
player
standing for something that's absolutely
false standing for something that they
are misinformed about and unfortunately
they listen to headline news
headlines are made to sell
and they're not necessarily true
this would be my strong strong message
to the players
and their national associations
so
moving into the next world there are
worries among the lgbt community
whether they will be welcomed in qatar
as an expat who's been living here for a
long time we know the culture we know
the laws but people coming in from
outside they don't what can you tell
them
to allay any fears
i've said it before a
qatar is a welcoming country qatar is a
tolerant country we as world cup
organizers
are welcoming all fans regardless of
their backgrounds ethnicity
religion
sexual orientation
at the end of the day everyone is
welcome here what we ask of people all
visiting fans and not just
people always talk about the lgbt
community we're asking all the fans to
make sure that they understand the norms
of the country they understand the laws
of the country as they would anywhere
else they go when they travel to to to
foreign countries they always
try to understand the culture the norms
the the laws of the country and that's
just normal and like i said
we need to demystify
qatar because there's nothing that is
different than qatar than the rest of
the world
people live here qatar is a very
international
country we have over 150 nationalities
living and working here in qatar and we
all co-exist peacefully and you know as
you know qatar is probably right now top
15 safest countries in the world number
one safest country in the world
arab country
people have nothing to worry about i
passed them the strong message you're
all welcome here
it's going to be an amazing event um the
world cup in qatar is going to be the
best and the most unique world cup ever
generally i think um people when they
travel to other countries they quickly
understand the norms in the country and
i think people are quite curious about
it right now and once people start to
plan their trips here they're going to
do a lot of research they will speak to
friends and family who live here
i've been to three world cups before and
i see that fans generally generally
respect the culture they respect the
norms they respect the laws of the
countries and we haven't really seen big
issues in previous world cups and i'm
confident that it's not going to be any
different
here in qatar
we're welcoming people we're tolerant
people and
i think it goes both ways people also
have to be tolerant of their host
and you know it's it's it's going to go
in that direction you've seen during the
years there's been some fan trouble
in england how's policing going to work
during the tournament well look uh the
good thing is we've had people there you
know we've been doing observation and
secundment programs and in major events
starting back in 2014 in brazil so
these are all key learnings that we use
and i think also during the euros
they've had
a review of what happened and and that's
being shared with us and we have people
that are in close contact with them
there to make sure things like this
don't happen i mean you can have as many
plans as you want but fans are fans
emotions run high in football and it's
uh it's how you deal with it it's how
you react to it um and you know it's
it's something you have to expect it's
something you have to be prepared for
and uh confident that all the organizers
and security personnel will be able to
deal with it
some football fans have been asking a
lot of questions my friends as well well
the first question is about tickets
which i don't have
but the second question is about alcohol
in the stadiums did you work out an
alcohol policy
look uh generally as you know that
alcohol is available in qatar and this
is something that a lot of people
ask about but a lot of people that live
in the region know this and understand
this and i don't think the question of
alcohol is going to be an issue
as much as people
predict or or even anticipate i think
people are going to come here and
realize tata is just like any other
country that they visit and go to
vacations on now so let's turn our focus
to the qatari national team
they didn't get the arab cup
but are we going to support them to
perform really well for the um world cup
their performance has been great
um they've
they've been involved in a lot of
competitions internationally copa
america
they've been in the european qualifiers
as a as a visiting
participating nation and they were
involved in the gold cup in the us and
this is all for the development we saw
their performance in the arab cup
they reached the semi-finals
unfortunately they couldn't make it to
the final but they're contesting
their you know they played very well
and their contestants
um for the world cup to go very far
hopefully
nasa finally
um
this is about you personally i haven't
seen you in quite some time you've lost
a little bit of weight a few gray hairs
how's your stress level are you feeling
the pressure does it get nearer look the
pressure is always there and the
pressure is good it keeps you on your
toes it keeps you prepared but i think
with the
passing of time with the
different test events that we've we've
gone through as a team with the team
growing
um gaining experience i think people
have become a lot more confident the
synergy between the team is there the
harmony is there
where the arab cup has really been a
tremendous opportunity for us um for
fifa we're all leaving this arab cup
more confident
for
a really amazing world cup